[Música]
culpable de cinco cargos fue encontrada
águila y maxwell pareja de la del
fallecido multimillonario jeffrey
epstein ambos señalados de liderar una
red de abuso sistemático de menores
desde mediados de la década de los
noventa
los presidentes de eeuu y rusia hablarán
este jueves telefónicamente sobre las
tensiones en ucrania yo bailén está
preocupado por la presencia de tropas
rusas en zona limítrofe y vladimir putin
exige garantías de seguridad a occidente
tenemos informe desde washington
hace dos años china alertó a la
organización mundial de la salud sobre
una neumonía viral que luego sería
reconocida como kobe de 19 del organismo
dice que las variantes de alta y omicron
crean un tsunami de positivos
gracias por quedarse con nosotros en
francés 24 bienvenidos a un nuevo
resumen informativo yo soy daniel
hablando ahora iniciamos con una noticia
de última hora y en desarrollo de cinco
cargos penales de los seis que era
acusada fue inculpada la británica
águila y maxwell era la pareja del
fallecido multimillonario jeffrey
epstein señalado de abusar
sistemáticamente de adolescentes y quien
se suicidó en su celda en manhattan en
2019 a la espera de su propio juicio
maxwell de 60 años es acusada de
reclutar y preparar a cuatro víctimas de
sting entre 1994 y 2004 y podría pagar
una pena de hasta 70 años de prisión a
esto dijo la fiscal federal adjunta
durante el juicio
gillane maxwell tomo sus propias
decisiones cometió crímenes mano a mano
con jeffrey epstein era una mujer adulta
que sabía exactamente lo que estaba
haciendo y nos vamos ahora para
washington para hablar de las crecientes
tensiones entre estados unidos y rusia
por ucrania este jueves los presidentes
job aiden y vladimir putin sostendrán
una llamada telefónica para discutir el
tema desde el gobierno estadounidense
señalan que byd en la insistirá a su
homólogo ruso que está preparado para
responder ante una eventual invasión a
territorio ucraniano por eso
establecemos comunicación con nuestro
corresponsal en washington en cristóbal
vázquez cristóbal buenas tardes y que
podrían adelantar los presidentes en
esta llamada que antecede al encuentro
binacional previsto para enero próximo
esta será la segunda llamada que tienen
los mandatarios en menos de un mes y se
da días antes de este encuentro que
tendrán oficiales rusos y
estadounidenses en ginebra en suiza el
10 de enero para tratar entre otros
temas en la participación de la otan en
el este de europa la principal el tema
principal de la llamada será la
presencia de rusos de tropas rusas en la
frontera entre rusia y ucrania y es que
a pesar de que hace unos días las
autoridades rusas informaron que habían
retirado 10.000 tropas de la frontera la
inteligencia estadounidense cree que
todavía hay cerca de 100.000 hombres
rusos en la frontera entre rusia y
ucrania y eso preocupa hasta autoridades
estadounidenses lo que está pidiendo
rusia sin embargo es que pues la otan
pare el aguán si de su presencia en
ucrania y en el este europeo
cristóbal le voy a cambiar de tema en
medio de las fiestas de fin de año y con
los ojos puestos sobre la variante
omicron cuál es el panorama actual del
cob y 19 eeuu
en eeuu y en washington donde es la
ciudad que más alta tasa tiene de
contagios de la variante omicron la
variante omicron representa el 90% de
los casos ya en eeuu y en todo el país
se reportan más de 53 millones de casos
de de de covite y pues es cerca de
800.000 personas ya han muerto debido al
cob y 19 en los últimos tres días cerca
de tres mil vuelos han tenido que
cancelarse esto ha generado todo un caos
en los principales aeropuertos del país
y se espera entonces que para fin de año
este causa aumente precisamente por la
cancelación de los vuelos muchas gracias
cristóbal era nuestro corresponsal en
washington y seguimos hablando de la
pandemia porque se cumplen dos años
desde que en 2019 en la víspera de año
nuevo china alertó a la organización
mundial de la salud sobre una veintena
de casos de una extraña neumonía que
luego sería el hobbit 19 dos años
después el director del organismo
asegura que la circulación se multa de
las variantes delta y omicron está
creando un tsunami de casos
mientras la mayor parte del planeta
celebraba el fin del 2019 una nueva
amenaza de energía el 31 de diciembre de
2019 china alertó a la organización
mundial de la salud de 27 casos de una
neumonía viral de origen desconocido
identificados en la ciudad de wuhan lo
que semanas más tarde sería catalogado
como el zarco 2 virus que produce el
kobe 19 oficialmente el primer caso de
la gripe de buján fuera de china se
registró en tailandia el 13 de enero de
2020 y rápidamente se extendió por todo
el mundo
el desarrollo y distribución de una
vacuna dividió la opinión pública siendo
la o ms principal promotor de la
inoculación pese a que más de 9 mil
millones de dosis se han administrado
mundialmente en un año las autoridades
sanitarias se lamentan no haber
alcanzado las metas propuestas alcohol
on leaders of reach can risk and
manufacturers hago un llamado a los
líderes de cada país ya los fabricantes
para que aprendan las lecciones de alfa
beta gamma delta y ahora omicron y
trabajen juntos para alcanzar el 70 por
ciento de cobertura de vacunación de
seis de 'time' este es el momento de
levantarse del cortoplacismo y proteger
a las poblaciones y las economías contra
futuras variantes game future trends con
la llegada de omicron y cumpliéndose el
segundo aniversario desde la aparición
del cob y de países como francia estados
unidos e india registran cifras récord
de contagios aunque no de muerte sobre
sus lluvias en quiso pedirme decirle a
los que no se han vacunado hay pocas
posibilidades de que puedan escapar esta
vez el virus se está extendiendo con
demasiada fuerza y los más propensos a
contraer el virus y desarrollar formas
sintomáticas y graves son los que no se
han vacunado una vez que las mascarillas
y el testeo ya son un denominador de
todo el mundo la oms se confía en que el
2022 ponga fin a la fase aguda de la
pandemia y en otras noticias de
coronavirus pero en américa latina
bolivia lucha por contener el creciente
número de casos pese a que no ha
detectado ninguno de contagio con la
variante omicron a los alcaldes de tres
ciudades suspendieron las fiestas de año
nuevo previamente autorizadas por su
parte del gobierno nacional dispuso la
obligatoriedad del carné de vacunación o
prueba pcr negativa desde el primero de
enero en los sitios de alta
concentración de personas
uva encendió las alarmas tras cinco días
de incremento en el número de casos
activos el gobierno anunció que
agilizará la vacunación de refuerzo y de
paso que la vacuna abdalá desarrollada
en este país comenzará a administrarse
en mexico luego de recibir la aprobación
de uso de emergencia por parte del
regulador este último país vivirá un fin
de año sin mayores restricciones sólo la
popular verbena navideña y un concierto
en la plaza del zócalo fueron
suspendidos y terminamos en argentina
donde este miércoles se registró un
nuevo récord de casos con 42 mil 32
positivos por kobe 19 la última vez que
el país había registrado tal cifra había
sido en mayo pasado la cifra de
contagios ya supera los 5 millones
nos quedamos en la región hoy guatemala
celebra el aniversario número 25 de la
firma de los acuerdos de paz que en 1996
pusieron fin a 36 años de conflicto
armado se estiman en casi 250 mil en las
víctimas y hoy en día muchos de los
convenios acordados siguen sin cumplirse
manuel a canales amplia
intensos años de negociaciones concluyan
con estas firmas era el 29 de diciembre
de 1996 y en ciudad de guatemala tras
las puertas del palacio nacional de la
cultura el gobierno daba el último paso
hacia la terminación del conflicto
interno del país junto con la unidad
revolucionaria nacional guatemalteca el
partido que recogía a las antiguas
guerrillas
y venimos para quedarnos
[Música]
una multitud eufórica se encontraba en
la plaza de la constitución a la
expectativa de que llegara el momento en
el que se proclamará el acuerdo que
acabaría con 36 años de conflicto un
período en el que según la comisión para
el esclarecimiento histórico cerca de
250 mil personas fallecieron durante los
enfrentamientos al mismo tiempo el
acuerdo pretendía acabar con la
desigualdad social y económica la
exclusión política de diversas
corrientes e ideologías y la vulneración
de los derechos humanos
muy contentos porque ojalá se lleve a
cabo y qué
que la paz sea duradera
25 años después algunos de los acuerdos
están lejos de cumplirse a pesar del
crecimiento económico
47% de la población sigue en la pobreza
las comunidades indígenas continúan
luchando por si el reconocimiento y la
violencia política se replicó en una ola
de violencia criminal el país ve un
incremento de los homicidios en este año
de más del 22% en los primeros 5 meses
con respecto a 2020 hasta que es
informativo quédense con nosotros
[Música]